Go ahead and go over to the cot. I don't like how he went down.
I need everybody.
I'll call.
I'll call
when Buffalo Bill
Safety Demar Hamlin
collapsed on the field in January.
Pete Laake immediately
thought about his son Peter.
It really brought back a lot of emotions.
And then still that's true
for two years ago.
Then a high school freshman
Peter Lake
was playing
defense for the Loyola dons
against the McDonough Eagles.
He was right around the 20 yard line.
What you're about to watch
is the exact moment
his heart stopped beating
I went to the ball
but stepped in front of it
and I just got hit like I've done that
many times before.
I kind of even Winston like,
just thinking in my head, Oh,
that one's going to hurt.
Jeremy Parr is the assistant
athletic director
and the head athletic trainer
at Peter's School.
That sunny day,
he was watching diligently
from the sidelines
because this shot was pretty hard.
I was watching Peter
instead of the course of the action
of the game.
I started looking for
what was going to happen next.
And then just like that, you know,
I like Dizzy and I
just, like, blacked out.
I could hear first
he had some agonizing breathing.
So it was like this
gasping or gurgling for air.
He's prone on the ground.
I checked for a pulse
and we didn't have on the diagnosis.
Commercial cordis a rare phenomenon
with fewer than 30 cases
reported every year.
And let me show you exactly
what happened to Peter.
His heart here
is contracting and relaxing.
That's a normal rhythm.
But at the exact millisecond,
the heart needs to recharge
before the next beat.
That's this little bump here.
The lacrosse ball
hit the left side of his chest.
As a result,
his heart never got the chance to relax.
It starts Deborah leading.
Instead,
Peter goes into cardiac arrest
and the clock starts ticking.
What was that like for you?
Didn't have time to think?
With no pulse, no breathing.
We needed to get the aid
and EMS activated as soon as possible.
And in Peter's case, it all worked
and fast, two to 3 minutes.
But watching all this as a parent,
I couldn't help but wonder,
what if this were my kid's school?
Your kid's school?
As part of a CNN investigation.
We learned that nowadays
at least
20 states have laws requiring heads.
And in reality,
about 70 to 80% of schools
have at least one defibrillator on hand.
But how accessible they are.
This is all
that is the real issue we uncovered.
What if it had happened,
you know, a few miles away from here?
It would have been
a totally different outcome.
You can do CPR to your blue in the face
and it's never going
to restart the heart.
It is 100% access to an I.D.
within a very timely period.
Turns out where you live
makes a big difference.
For example, in Ohio, in Michigan,
more than 70% of public schools had AIDS,
but in locations
that simply couldn't be reached in time.
In Oregon,
just half of schools had an I.D.
accessible within 4 minutes
of all sports venues.
In Vermont,
despite 81% of schools having an I.D.
just 16% of them
had them located at fields or arenas.
And about half the time
they were in the school nurse's office
or the lobby.
This is an example of a poor
We learned that athletic trainers
are critical
in schools that had athletic trainers.
We're more likely to have AIDS.
The chance of survival
from a cardiac arrest
nearly doubled to over 80%
if an athletic trainer or aid were used.
But as things stand now,
a third of the country schools
don't have anyone in that position.
All athletes should be afforded
the same resources that we have here.
The Division
One athletes in college
have an professional sports as well.
That's the thing.
It's availability and access.
Both are crucially important.
And it's one of the most important things
you can do for your kids.
Make sure AIDS are available
and accessible in your kid's school.
It saved Peter Lake's life.
And allowed for moments like this
Now, a lot of people may be wondering
about the cost of these.
It is 1000 to $2,000
depending on the model But, Jake,
that's not a yearly cost.
I mean, you know,
as long as they stay charged,
they can be used for many years,
need roughly one aid per 500 students.
That's what parents should be asking for.
And again, make sure they're accessible.
Not that they just have them,
but they're accessible,
preferably within 2 minutes, Jake.
As you saw there, it can save a life.
Makes a huge difference.